i feel like i look so silly
[Music]
hey guys i haven't done a get ready with
me in such a long time
and i figured i haven't talked to you
guys in forever
so you guys are going to be getting
ready with me but before we continue i
do want to make a shout out to our
sponsor squarespace thank you so much
for sponsoring this video
make sure that you guys stick around
later on because we'll be talking about
them at the end of the video
so let's get ready let's beautify me
first of all i wanted to talk about
how i've been doing my hair recently so
i know you guys have noticed
i'm now doing the part down the middle
which by the way
is perfect for my head because i have
two like cowlicks on each side right
here so
every time i try to do like a what is it
called the side flip or like the side
part it was always a disaster for me
so having the middle part is like yes
this is exactly what is perfect for my
head like i said i just got out of the
shower so my hair is still wet
and i have been trying to embrace my
natural waves what i found out was
i was actually showering wrong in case
you guys didn't know you're not supposed
to
add your shampoo super vigorously to
your scalp because you irritate your
scalp and also you're not supposed to
add your conditioner
like this like that's what that's what i
used to do i didn't know
but that's how i used to add my
conditioner ever since i stopped ever
since i started adding my conditioner
just by like
raking it through the ends i do feel
like it's made a difference in my hair
also what i've been doing as soon as i
get out i add
this leave-in conditioner that i use
from function of beauty
and i just add like i rake it in and it
makes my hair
so freaking soft i love it
next what i've been using is this diva
curl styling cream
and that's really enhancing my waves my
beautiful waves
i just added to the ends of my hair like
i don't put anything on my scalp
[Music]
okay then when i do this i like scrunch
it up
and what i was doing before was using a
diffuser
and like blow drying my hair in like low
heat and just figuring out that whole
diffuser situation but
i found out that my hair doesn't like it
doesn't like using a diffuser
so instead i plop my hair now
girls who have curly hair you already
know what i'm talking about i get a
cotton t-shirt
i lay it down and then i wrap my hair in
it and they call it like
plopping so like this lay it down stick
my hair in it
and bring the bottom of the shirt up i
use the
blades here to tie it and that's how you
plop i'm actually not a huge fan of this
because
my hair like here at the top it ends up
being like really smushed
i think it's just cause i'm doing it too
tight anyway that's what i'm doing for
my hair these days
i'm moving on to makeup i know i'm not
gonna talk about
every single thing i'm doing to my face
instead
i wanna talk to you guys about what's
been going on in my life
because i know you haven't heard from me
in some time
and i miss you guys so just today
we uploaded a live update video on big
mood realize that i haven't talked to
you guys
my tiffin case fan like we're the
closest to you guys but i've completely
neglected you guys
and i'm sorry for that i'm gonna try not
to neglect you guys anymore because i
missed you
um i think i've just been so caught up
in
life to be honest with you guys i have
developed some sort of weird
thing with vlogging i think because i've
been doing it so long and
it's just been so much a part of my life
that i think i needed a break from it
for some time
and i think that's why you guys haven't
seen me very often here but anyway
i'm ready i'm back so to let you guys
know what we did talk about on big moon
i guess go a little deeper well for
starters i talked about my grandma
and how my grandma has been going
through some health issues
and i actually flew out to mexico to go
be with her this is back in april and
i didn't post about it and talk about it
i didn't you know it was just very
private and personal and
scary because i was really scared for my
grandma but luckily she's okay now she's
she's done a lot better we're super
thankful
but we were really scared there for a
second and what happened was
she had a couple bad falls to the point
where
she was unable to use her
right arm and her right leg so she was
no longer able to
walk able to you know go to the restroom
on her own
she started having to need to wear a
diaper and like help
like take baths and help take you know
feed her and stuff and it was just
really rough because my grandma is
she's always been super strong super
independent
like superwoman she was always like on
the go and always wanted to do things on
her own
so seeing her like this was really
devastating
for everyone for the whole family and
especially for her because she's a proud
woman
so it was just really rough and the
whole family came together
and you know everyone's oh man
dang it i got makeup on my white robe
anyway everyone's just been taking care
of her and being there for her
and you know when i was there i did see
her get
progressively better throughout the days
that i was there so i was really
thankful
to be able to witness that and just be
there for her
because it was really concerning when i
got there she was not remembering who i
was
she was repeating words that we would
ask her like if we'd say like hey
grandma she'd go
hey grandma hey grandma hey grandma like
like her brain was a little scrambled
so that was really concerning you know
because especially
i've never seen my grandma like that but
yeah so like i said she has gotten a lot
better she's been able to now regain
mobility in her arm and slowly in her
leg
and she's she's getting better so thank
god for that another thing i talked
about was my health
so i've actually gone through some
health stuff and i only talked about one
thing
on big mood i don't think i'm ready to
talk about the second thing but
eventually i'll let you guys know but in
terms of the thing that i did already
talk about
i had a health scare where i thought
that i might have
had lupus i had talked about some of my
symptoms
on jk news and a fan hit me up it was
like hey
have you ever thought about getting
tested for lupus because my mom and my
sister had lupus and you're the symptoms
that you're talking about jk news sounds
really similar like you might want to
get that checked out so i was like oh my
god thank you so much like i had never
considered that like i have heard of
lupus but i never really knew what it
was
exactly i found out it's an autoimmune
disease and it ends up affecting people
in all kinds of sorts of ways and when i
started googling i'm like
holy cow i literally have almost all
these symptoms so i got really convinced
that i had lupus and i was really scared
too
for a few months i put it off for a few
months to go get
checked and to go to a doctor and i just
didn't
i don't know like i was i was more
afraid of the diagnosis
than me just not knowing like i was more
comfortable not knowing i guess
in that time it was just too scary to
know the truth but eventually i
built up the courage and i'm like okay
let's just go to my doctor and let's go
get some tests let's see what's going on
so the initial test that came back was
testing if i had any
anti and antibodies which means like
cells that are attacking my own cells
that's what autoimmune
diseases do it's just like your own body
attacking your healthy tissues or like
your healthy cells so that first test
came back
and it was positive meaning they did
detect those cells in my body
and i was like oh my god that's it i
have lupus great
like oh god like what's gonna happen
like it's just it's terrifying because
i it's not so much nowadays but i do
know like
back in the day lupus was pretty much a
death sentence and i found this out
because i
later talked to someone who actually has
lupus and we sat down and had lunch
and she told me about her experience and
she also told me like you know once you
have one autoimmune disease
the next one like they just like pile on
and i was just like oh my god is this my
future this is crazy like
i just started spiraling and so my
doctor recommended that i go see
a rheumatologist and so i found one she
looked at those first initial tests
and she was like you know what looking
at your organs and like
how everything is working i'm kind of
surprised that they said it was positive
to begin with because
it doesn't like she's like to me it
seems like
you don't have lupus it seems like
you're pretty okay but let's go ahead
and do
a second test a more thorough test
and let's see what that one says so then
i waited
a couple weeks for that second one and
once the results came for that
she was like yeah you know everything
looks pretty good
i don't feel confident in diagnosing you
with lupus at this time so i'm like okay
but then one of the symptoms that i was
that is like the main symptom
that is the most uncomfortable for me is
joint pain
i've been having a lot of joint pain on
and off for
like five years now that i've just kind
of not really thought much about i'm
like oh yeah
my elbow hurts right now but no big deal
it'll go away in a couple days and it
does
and so i just never really thought about
it and so i told her about
it she concluded that i have a very rare
autoimmune disease called palindromic
rheumatism
and that's pretty much a form of
arthritis
if i'm gonna have arthritis from what i
know like this one
is the one to get because it
it's not perm like it doesn't like the
paint isn't consistent
it comes and goes and whenever i do have
joint pain
my joints aren't deteriorating like it's
not causing damage to my joints not
like rheumatoid arthritis which is the
more severe intense one
that one actually does like deteriorate
your joints over time like you'll end up
having to replace joints
pretty much that's what i found out
about my health yeah i just had a really
really really crazy april because a lot
of stuff happened in april there's other
things like i said that
eventually i will discuss and you know
talk about
right now part of it is i'm not ready
and another part of it is
you know there's just i'm not ready hold
on i gotta figure out how to put this
up this is falling on me should work
yeah some other stuff that's been
happening is uh we just got back from
dallas we didn't vlog that for you guys
like i said there's
been like this weird like vacation i
guess from vlogging so we didn't vlog
that and actually we did vlog hawaii by
the way
we do have footage of it but we didn't
like we had a lot of b-roll but we
didn't actually vlog
so i don't know do you guys actually
care to see that footage because i know
a lot of you guys are like oh my god
this was months ago why do we care about
this now
so that's why we were just like ah it
just got too late we just never released
it
but if you guys do want to see the
hawaii footage still even though it's
pretty old let me know we'll get that
out for you guys but
anyways about dallas so we spent a whole
week there with the chant clan
it was really nice to see everyone and
spend time and just
you know bond because we don't get to
see them that often
but the main reason why we were there
though was because we were
there for the grand opening of junebe
and so there's now a gym being dallas in
case you haven't heard
and it's just it's been so awesome
because this particular zoombi is
actually franchised
out by the chang clan so that particular
location
in dallas is owned by the tang clan it
was really awesome
we ended up doing a meet and greet there
if you guys follow me on instagram you
saw my stories it was super cool
it was so beautiful to get to meet
everyone
like this has only been the second meet
and greet that we
we've ever had out in dallas and i don't
know just every time like meeting
the people behind the lens is just so
like fulfilling i don't know it just
feels really great
to actually meet you guys in person and
hug you and like hear from you and like
answer your questions like it was just
it was so fulfilling
i was actually really surprised that how
many people showed up too by the way i
gotta be honest i was like man
it's been so long we barely even
uploaded anymore like or i
barely even post on instagram anymore
like social media life to me i've just
kind of like
let go a little bit over this past
year i was just like man no one's gonna
come but
yeah you guys showed up and a lot of you
showed up so i'm like oh my god thank
you guys i did not think
you were gonna be here but it meant a
lot it really meant a lot to me
all of you guys and just yeah like hear
from you and answer
all your questions and by the way almost
everyone was saying
that they've watched jk news since
middle school
and i was like excuse me isaac is in
middle school and there is
no way i would let him watch jacob's no
where were your parents like come on
that's just insane to me that little
isaacs were watching jk news with all
the wild stuff we were saying like oh my
gosh it's not for kids
but i guess that was the appeal right
like you guys were like
oh this grown-up talk you can't we're
not supposed to listen to this
yeah that's really cool and a lot of you
guys were like you guys raised me
and i'm like oh no but no it's really
cool it's really cool hearing from
everybody
[Music]
by the way i'm not going anywhere i just
really wanted to play with some makeup
and talk to you guys
i actually was brave and bold
and i put eye shadow on for the meet and
greet
and so that kind of i don't know it kind
of like sparked a little
makeup artist in me and i'm like oh i
want to play with different colors
so i have this palette from what is this
color oh from colourpop
and it just has like the cutest colors
ever and i actually was wearing
like this euphoric one and then the
mesmerized one
like this is kind of what i wore to the
meet and greet but there's like these
bold like greens and stuff where i'm
like
should i try it for this purple it's
like purple in here
and like bright pink i don't know what
should i do you guys
because i'm feeling adventurous right
now i think i decided
i am going to go with
well since i'm not going anywhere it
doesn't matter i'm going to do the blue
okay
because this is a really pretty color i
really like it a lot i guess like this
one and that one
i don't know i'm not a i'm not a pro
okay
don't come for me makeup artist i know i
know i'm not i'm not the best okay
i'm scared okay let's start with the
[Music]
you bass the basics where it's like you
put a base and you put a light color
here and you put a dark color here
and that's it
oh what if i mix this one and that one
look i'm gonna do this one and then that
one
[Music]
i don't even think i'm using the right
brush by the way i'm using this one
i don't know that's what i like about
makeup though it's just it's fun it
doesn't have to be perfect
you don't have to be a professional you
just
play with it's like playing with paint
[Music]
okay moment of truth
okay guys i'm done just kidding
now this is the hard part is blending
the dark
color oh no oh no
oh no guys i don't know what i'm doing
[Music]
this is tragic i think i know where i
went wrong with this one i was blending
in
not supposed to do that you're supposed
to blend out right because then it ended
up moving all of it in well this is why
practice ladies and gentlemen who love
makeup
without practice you won't learn from
your mistakes oh yeah this is a hot mess
i don't like it you know the last time i
put a dark eyeshadow on my eyelids
i feel like it was like 2009 or
something really a long time ago
over 10 years ago you can tell like this
is like some
10 years ago style makeup they're not a
blend teach me
youtube you gotta teach me i don't know
how i'm gonna fix this you guys
sorry you're watching a train wreck
i don't know does it look yeah it looks
pretty bad on camera too it's really bad
in person and it looks really bad on
camera too am i supposed to like pull
the dark all the way up to my eyebrow i
just have too much
eyelid to eyebrow space look like i
belong in the 80s right now i don't know
i guess i just gotta own it at this
point right
own it
[Music]
okay my camera overheated so it shut
down
and in that time that i was cooling down
i re-plucked my hair
and i did this so i looked on instagram
really quick i'm like
what are girls doing with their makeup
these days and everyone puts their dark
eyeshadow like across the whole lid
so i did that and this is what came out
i don't know you guys i don't know i'm
trying to salvage this but it's not
working
okay let's try to put some glitter and
see if it makes it better
putting on this this one right here
let's see how this turns out oh there's
like
nothing coming off you really dig in
there i don't know
i'm really feeling like washing this off
my face now i
was trying to be bold i was trying to be
adventurous i think this is a fail
i just have to take the l let me see if
i can at least
finish the look
[Music]
oh i have so much eye shadow down here
you know what now i understand why
makeup artists
do their face last versus the eyeshadow
and then their face now i get it
looks like i have some really dark
circles now okay
so this is what's going on a lot of
eye shadow down here i'm not a fan
but i don't know if there's anything
else i can do you guys
my skill set is extremely limited
so you know how like a work in progress
is very
ugly in the process like during the
process but then at the final result
it's like
oh snaps that was the end result well
would you look at that
and that's what i'm kind of hoping for
this look
[Music]
okay well my camera overheated and i
needed to cool down
once again this is what i did in the
meantime i put eyeliner
and eyelashes i look like a pirate
i'm gonna take off this this t-shirt now
and see how the plopping
came along okay
so still needs to dry it's still
very wet but when it dries though it
dries into these beautiful waves
dude i honestly feel like lamb chop
right now i know it's a really old
reference but google it
puppet it has eyelashes i feel like
laptop
lipstick that's what i need i have a
whole bunch of nyx makeup
also all these like really fun eyeliner
colors too i haven't used maybe in a
future video
i'll get even more adventurous oh yeah
there's also these like
face stencil thingies that i can like
use
look how cool is this it's my face
cute huh i guess i'll pick red
red with this bold dark look might as
well
go full force with the red lipstick or
lips it's not open yet i feel like i
can't even see
everything's like this i almost never
wear eyelashes
and i was wearing them for a little bit
because it was cute
but it wasn't these these are like
really really heavy
bold eyelashes okay here we go
i feel like a clown yeah nice
feels nice on my lips all right guys
this is what i came up with to be honest
i hate it
but let me know what you guys think i
feel like
jack sparrow that's what this look is
giving me jack sparrow vibes especially
since my hair is still wet there we go
this is like so not me but
it's okay we came here today to have
some fun and
explore our creative side with some
makeup
and this is what we came up with we aka
me
so i'm gonna be looking up makeup
tutorials to
fix this and maybe in the next makeup
video
i will be able to present something
better to you but i think honestly like
with the eyelashes and all that like i
feel like i'm ready
to go hit a club in the daytime i'm just
gonna
make my own club here in my bedroom
close the blinds
pump some music do some disco lights
and there we go just kidding i don't
know what i'm saying all right guys well
thank you so much for watching let me
know in the comments what did you think
did i do an okay job i don't know
because honestly if you say i did it i
do not blame you because i agree with
you this
came out wow but i still want to hear
your guys's thoughts
let me know also let me know what you
guys have been up to because
i want to connect with you guys like i
said i've been missing you
and i'm back though no more blog
vacation okay and once again thank you
squarespace for sponsoring today's video
squarespace is a powerful easy to use
platform where you can create your own
website
with squarespace you can connect with
your audience send email communication
leverage audience insights and generate
revenue if you want to blog squarespace
has powerful blogging tools to help
build a community
it can display all your social media
posts in one place so your followers can
easily
find and share them if you want to start
your own store squarespace has powerful
ecommerce extensions
new third-party tools can help you
manage inventory promote products
streamline bookkeeping
and ship items across the globe go to
squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
tiffcase to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or
domain thank you guys so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed this
very odd get ready with me yeah maybe
next time
uh i'll actually piece an entire outfit
because this is just me
in my robe which i stained i'm gonna
have to
tie that real quick anyway i'm gonna
take off now
i'm gonna take this off now
[Music]
me